but knowing where you are today
and having left the democratic party and
started a forward party
what are some things now you
agree
that the left is doing right the
democrats are doing right what was
something where it's a tipping point to
say i'm just and i can't get behind that
and was there anything the republicans
are doing for you to say i'm not fully
there to say i'm a republican myself
but these are some of the things i do
agree with the republicans on what
they're doing all right so this is one
of the problems of the two-party system
is you have these kind of increasingly
ideological conversations and uh folks
on one side will be like hey government
should be doing all these things and
then uh the other side would be like no
government shouldn't be doing those
things and i think what most of your
listeners want is for government to
actually be good at the things it's
doing
[Laughter]
if you look at the press what is the
press always about in terms of these
political conversations how much money
is going to this how much money is going
to that wouldn't cut this we're going to
take that and then you're like where the
heck is this money going is it being
spent effectively why do i have the the
sinking feeling that you could power
more money into the system and it
wouldn't necessarily help during the
swamp one of the the clearest examples
of it in new york city
is there is a lot of money getting spent
in the new york city public school
system on educating these kids and the
results have not kept pace with the
investment and so if you look at this
and you go to someone on the left be
like hey what the problem what the
problem is they'll be like spend more
money and you're like i'm not really
sure that's gonna do it because you're
already spending whatever it is like 15
000 ahead
per year where if you do the math on a
you know classroom of 30 kids you're
like wait a minute that's like a
significant amount of money and it's
certainly not
uh bearing fruit
so this is what's missing from our
political discourse and i'm going to
suggest that this is what most business
people and entrepreneurs would naturally
do it's like you show up you'll be like
okay like how are we spending it what
are we getting in return
is it working is it efficient is it
accountable the fact is politicians just
kind of come and go money gets spent
they show up they cut a rib and they
announce a program does anyone actually
come back to see hey did that program
actually work did that bear bear fruit
no by the time
you know but by the time you get any
results of that the politicians moved on
everyone's moved on the press doesn't
actually drill about the efficacy of
these things so so that's where i am
it genuinely is this middle road that i
think most americans have common sense
about it's like look should the
government be doing some things yes in
my opinion i mean i'm not like a you
know like
someone who thinks the government should
be doing nothing but it should be doing
what it's doing at a much higher level
more effectively more accountably and
more efficiently if you enjoyed this
short clip click over here to watch
another short clip and if you want to
watch the entire episode the entire
podcast click here
[Music]